piquet je vous fait entendre quelques
réactions qu'on est allé chercher ce
matin ça va amener l'ouvragé servir et
bell dit ça vraiment pour l'économie ici
je pense qu'on restructure la compagnie
comme il faut autant difficultés là je
pense que on fait des bonnes choses qui
sonne à lyon qui qui avec les essais
donne de bons résultats donc ça devrait
être un bonheur un bel avion pour moi
c'est faux c'est pas de jeter de
l'argent par les fenêtres en plus et ont
été chercher une garantie comme quoi que
l'avion considéré les fabriquer ici puis
déménage répondu j'aime c'est un gros
investissement pour mirabel c'est des
emplois évidemment due au dessus de 12
cents emplois ici alors donc on est que
heureux d'apprendre que le gouvernement
vient en aide mais dans un autre sens
c'est inquiétant je vous dirais c'est
comme si ça serait la dernière chance
monsieur des roues bonsoir à vous pour
soi c'est ce que beaucoup beaucoup de
gens souligne la d analyse l'opposition
bien sûr mais plusieurs analyses si vous
avez mis vous êtes vraiment accroché
vous fait un chèque un très gros chèque
à la cseries ont créé une entreprise on
sort la cseries de bombardier ont créé
une coentreprise avec le gouvernement du
québec plutôt qu'à voir et des lentilles
sté générale l'entité maire de
bombardier qui a été peut-être moins
puisqu'il est en fait vous voyez vous
quand on regarde la société dans
laquelle on est vers 6 dans la société
en commandite première chose qu'il faut
regarder pour le risque c'est la qualité
du bilan le bilan d'ouverture et le
bilan d'ouverture qui sera fait on l'a
vu aujourd'hui il y en a effacé beaucoup
d'investissements qui avait été fait
dans le cseries on parle de trois points
du milliard us on parle de littéralement
4 milliards qui ont été effacées des
livres de la société de merde à laquelle
on me dit vous auriez dû investir mans
enfin moi j'ai investi dans le bilan
épuré mais exactement dans la société
que je veux voir grandir qui est l'avion
du futur et non dans la société mère qui
répartis partout dans le monde pour
donner les liquidités à toutes les
composantes informatiques sont pas
nécessairement celle au lac en mai
monsieur daou donc vous reconnaissez
qu'il n'y a plus de risques
à faire ça qu'à aider une société mère
où il ya des composantes qui on le sait
fonctionne très bien il ya plus de
risques tant mieux ça décolle la cseries
tout le monde le souhaite mais ça
décolle pas les québécois viennent de
prendre un gros risque de risque où ils
vous d'investir dans un avion qui est
sur le point d'être certifié qu'il
premier avion de ligne de du 21e siècle
et les concurrents ont des avions qu'ils
ont mis sur lesquels ils ont fait des
mises à jour et quand je regarde encore
une fois le bilan de la société dans
laquelle j'ai des ch'ti et je vous
invite à regarder le bilan du groupe
dans lequel on me dit que j'aurais dû
investir
regardez les deux et vous ne gérez après
lequel des deux vous dans lequel des
douves l'inversé surtout si je veux
sauver des emplois au québec
en fait j'ai de bombardier mais c'est
l'industrie aéronautique du québec qu'on
protège donc vous n'avez aucun doute que
la cseries va décoller parce que gérald
le mentionne on le dit depuis des années
maintenant il faut comprendre pour que
les gens nous suivent à la maison les
deux gros géant sur la planète la
européen airbus américain boeing qui
sont très aidé e par leurs gouvernements
respectifs
les gouvernements ont voulu éjecté de la
patinoire bombardier qui a voulu aller
les compétitionner avec un avion la
cseries 230 et ça en place ce n'est pas
jouer ça peut-être peut-être que ça
risque de ne pas décoller je l'écouté
avec 240 commandes fermes
on nous dit qu'on n'avait pas eu une
nouvelle commande c'est vrai mais on ne
transférer on le transforme et au
dernier salon du bourget on s'en
souviendra des engagements ou des
manifestations d'intérêt en commandes
fermes
en fait si on regarde les manifestations
d'intérêt les commentaires c'est 103
appareils qui sont actuellement en voie
d'être d'être construit des commandes
sont en voie de se réaliser
la grande difficulté était est ce que
bombardier abandonnera le civis et
c'était ça qui était la question sur les
marchés et si vous étiez le président
d'une compagnie aérienne vous alliez
putté avant de m'engager au mafieux rixe
composantes ont continuellement
ils agissent exactement où c'est
exactement où on se positionne à dire
oui cette compagnie leur vote de cet
avion neuf envolé mais sedan aussi le
québec
t'es pas entrer dans la danse avec
bombardier n'était pas devenu un
partenaire de la cseries la cseries
risquait de mourir avant le premier
envol n'est ce pas vous l'avez un peu
dit aujourd'hui en dix ans le risque
était plus grand de rien faire le risque
moi je pense que la société aurait
probablement pu s'en sortir autrement
mais il cherchait des partenaires qui
n'ont pas trouvé depuis trois mois ils
n'ont pas trouvé à une date
il s'était fixé qui était le 29 octobre
souvenons nous que bombardier s'était
engagé à donner de bonnes nouvelles aux
investisseurs et leur bon nous on a
voulu que les bonnes nouvelles arrivent
on veut s'assurer que l'avion va
décoller vos dans tous les sens du terme
et que les commandes vont continuer de
grandir
c'est pour ça et je le répète on est
intervenu à ce point l'homme et à
peut-être qu'elle ait eu plus de
difficultés moi je ne voulais pas
m'inscrire dans une entreprise qui a des
difficultés
je veux protéger ses employés au québec
très bien sûr le ministre on va suivre
évidemment c'est avec beaucoup d'intérêt
merci beaucoup merci monsieur je peine à
domont soir enfin mathieu roy se paiera
d'où vous ne dites pas aujourd'hui vous
qu'on mette trop d'argent à bombardier
mais vous dites si je vous comprends
bien qu'on le met pas au bon endroit
c'est exact monsieur roy donc la
transaction est mal structuré le
gouvernement qui donc gère les fonds
publics l'argent des contribuables
auraient dû minimiser son risque et
faire en sorte que l'injection de
capital est évidemment vous rendez
compte qu'il s'agit pas de nous sommes
peu importantes bien au contraire se
fasse au sein de la compagnie mère
plutôt que de la faire dans une coquille
une coque est essentiellement corporatif
qui a été créé aux fins de cette
transaction
vous savez si le gouvernement avait
choisi d'
mettre son argent sous forme de
souscription au capital de la compagnie
mère bombardier elles auraient ils
auraient pardon minimiser les risques
pour pouvoir bénéficier également d
autres activités qui sont très
importantes pour bombardier les
actionnaires de bombardier loncin grougi
les intérêts de l'ensemble des
actionnaires avec l'ensemble des
contribuables dont on s'accroche donc
uniquement à la cseries de bombardier
si ça décolle pu tant mieux pour tous
les québécois pour bombardier
si ça décolle ça va bien aller mais ce
que vous dites c'est que si ça décolle
pas c'est un milliard trois cents
millions que l'on perd autrement dit non
je ne dis pas ça je dis qu'il est
important et je les mentionnaient gelé
interpellé à plusieurs reprises autant
titre de député de saint jérôme et
porte-parole de l'économie à l'endroit
du ministère ou autant aujourd'hui comme
chef de l'opposition officielle à
l'endroit du premier ministre qu il nous
apparaissait incontournable et essentiel
même impératif de soutenir une
entreprise comme bombardier mais encore
faut-il comprendre la finance encore
faut-il comprendre l'économie et
investir au bon endroit pour minimiser
les risques
nous les avons invités nous nous étions
réjouis d'apprendre hier que le
gouvernement justement s'engager dans
cette direction or il se trouve
qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes obligés
conclure que le premier ministre est un
piètre négociateur n'est pas en mesure
de bien saisir tous les tenants et
aboutissants des structures en matière
de transactions financières
l'objectif de soutenir la série c'est ce
programme aurait t t 4 est également été
en mesure de pouvoir se décliner par
l'investissement on aide la compagnie
mère mais il aurait minimisé le rôle de
l'apport et du risque associé à la série
en faisant en sorte que les actionnaires
soient alignées avec les contribuables
que les contribuables puissent
bénéficier également de la croissance
des activités que sont la division
ferroviaire est ainsi également les
autres produits de
division aéronautique pensons aux
challengers pensons aux hadjis pensons
au plus 400 ils sont nombreux les
produits vedettes qui ont énormément de
succès chez bombardier alors pourquoi
cantonner ce risque uniquement la série
alors que ce sont les actionnaires de
bombardier qui vont bénéficier de l'aide
du gouvernement
on a l'impression qu'on a vu depuis deux
trois semaines bombardier qui se cherche
un partenaire pour la cseries
ils ont cherché avec airbus a pas
fonctionné est-ce que vous avez cette
impression aussi comme beaucoup
d'analystes que c'est vraiment la
dernière chance là on essaie on met le
paquet parce que c'est un beaucoup de
gens le disent et un très bon avion
potentiellement les deux gros géant se
sont ligués contre bon darty et écoutez
monsieur roy c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous étions favorables et même
que nous avons incité le gouvernement à
s'intéresser à ce dossier à prendre ses
responsabilités parce que vous venez de
le mentionner
donc le marché américain' marché
européen stone écosystèmes un écosystème
entre le militaire et le civil et c'est
la raison pour laquelle nous devons
accompagner comme collectivité le fruit
de cette innovation
la balance commerciale qui est lié
justement au secteur de l'exportation
la créa si le métier d'un siège social à
montréal et tout l'écosystème qui
l'accompagnent maintenant que la
transaction soit structurée de la façon
dont elle est elle le elle est
malheureusement préjudiciable aux
contribuables est plutôt bénéficiaires
aux actionnaires il aurait fallu aligner
les intérêts des actionnaires et des
contribuables et je pose la question
comme je lé fais ce matin au premier
ministre comment se fait-il que la
caisse de dépôt qui en cette matière
parce que cette expertise financière
nous l'avons développée au québec depuis
de nombreuses années et j'ai eu moi même
l'occasion de le savoir parce que j'ai
transiger à plusieurs reprises avec le
représentant de la caisse de dépôt
ils sont conscients des risques qu'ils
existent qui existe lorsqu'il entre dans
une transaction et ils savent que ça
requiert également
une gouvernance corporative qui n'est
pas le cas dans cette transaction il y
avait 15 de dépôt n'est pas présente
alors sachez que lorsque la caisse se
fait présenter un bon dîner excusez moi
l'expression une bonne transaction elle
est présent s'il se trouve qu'elle n'est
pas présent être qu'on comprend le super
radio en conclusion qu'il y avait un
sentiment d'urgence manifestement est
long il ne reste parce qu'une fois que
c'est fait il ne reste j'imagine vous
est de cet avis aussi ne reste qu'à
espérer que ça décolle cette histoire
l'a finalement là la série si oui vous
avez raison de le mentionner
nous sommes tous d'avis qu'il s'agit
d'un projet porteur de d'un aéronef de
grande qualité qui est des attributs
extrêmement compétitif mais qui fait
face et vous l'avez décrit à un
environnement extrêmement concurrentiel
lit des écosystèmes militaires et civils
pierre karl péladeau cher l'opposition
merci à la prochaine merci et du roi
noir merci au revoir